Are you single now?
I mean, always.
I think you need to live in a place
where you're perpetually single.
I'm single.
Even when
you're with someone,
I think you're single, always.
I'm really good at being alone.
Are you good at being alone?
So good at being alone.
It's my favorite thing.
When I've run, like with a bunch of people,
I'm, oh, I love you guys, but, like,
I'm truly myself when I'm just alone,
and I think my album was such a manifestation of just,
like, pure alone time.
I'm an only child.
Do you have siblings?
Look at us?
I think being an only child and, you know,
loving that alone time was kind of
one of the reasons that I got so into songwriting,
it's 'cause, you know,
songwriting is kind of like a friend for you,
and so I think that's like
a really amazing part of creation,
and I think that also comes from being alone
and also being bored sometimes, too.
I think boredom is, like,
what's the word?
Catalyst for a bunch of creative things.
Can anybody get to boredom
in this ADD-enriched social inundation society?
How do you get to boredom?
Oh, it's very hard.
Yeah.
I think I, like, force myself to do it now, too.
I definitely force myself
to sometimes sit at the piano,
even if I have, like, no ideas,
just to, like, fool around.
And I think there's a really, like,
cool thing about doing something like that.
Do you ever, like, force your phone off?
Take, like, space from things?
Yes.
What is your process?
I need to.
I very much restrict all of my social media,
because I think it's, A, such a time-suck,
and B, it can make you, like,
so sad and depressed sometimes
'cause people can be really weird on there,
but, yeah, that's a big part of, you know,
kind of maintaining mental health in today's age.
I do think because we're moving into, like,
Meatless Mondays and the plant-based movement
and mental health is so prevalent, like,
why are we not fighting for, like,
a once a week phone shutdown?
We should.
Literally, Sunday, no one's on their phones.
No responding to texts.
No Instagram posts.
Let's start it.
I'm serious.
There is a shift,
a church-like spiritual shift when you disconnect,
and I think we need to make it this, like,
cool, hip, collective, amazing movement
that will literally change people's lives and days,
because when you unplug,
the metaphor is too apt and perfect,
you make room for other stuff.
Totally.
I love that.
(audience applauding)
Oh, what a dream come true.
She is the best.
(upbeat music)